You might not be scared of zombies on tv,
but you should definitely be
scared of these fungi in real life.
For those expecting to see a one-to-one recreation
of Naughty Dog and Sony's 2013 PlayStation 3 game,
"The Last of Us," in the 2023 adaptation by HBO,
the opening likely came as quite the surprise.
Instead of opening with Sarah giving Joel his
birthday present, we instead jump back to 1968,
where we see an epidemiologist named Dr. Neuman
warn the world of a fungus called cordyceps,
which can take over the minds of
ants and bend them to their will.
"The fungus starts to direct the
ant's behavior telling it where to go,
what to do like a puppeteer with a marionette."
In the world of "The Last of Us," which
although grounded for a zombie show and game,
is still full of impossible creatures and
abominations, one might be forgiven for
assuming that the cordyceps fungus
is a fictional creation. However,
we regret to inform you that the cordyceps fungus
is real, and it's just as scary as it sounds.
Much like the scientist discussed in the premiere,
there are types of fungi that feed on the living.
One such fungus is Ophiocordyceps unilateralis,
which National Geographic reported on in 2019.
The fungus floods ants' brains with chemicals,
takes over their muscles, and controls them
to move to the perfect height and temperature
for the fungus to grow, then spreads
its spores to control even more ants.
There are a couple of differences between how
this fungus works and how it works in humans in
"The Last of Us," however. For starters,
although it affects the ants' brains,
it doesn't actually invade them, as scientists
found no fungal cells within the ants' brains.
That means that the fungal outgrowths found
in Infected such as Clickers in the show and
games wouldn't be possible with this fungus,
even if it were somehow able to infect humans.
However, there is another fungus that
does create a scarily similar outgrowth
from the head. According to National Geographic,
the fungus Ophiocordyceps sinensis can form
a growth from the heads of moth caterpillars.
While you couldn't pay us enough to go anywhere
near those things, the infected caterpillars
are actually used in traditional Tibetan and
Chinese medicine to cure all sorts of diseases.
Not all types of cordyceps are malignant toward
their hosts, as species that take root in Japanese
cicadas may help them process nutrients from sap.
Imagine an alternate universe to "The Last of Us"
where instead of causing an Infected horde, the
cordyceps fungus becomes a popular snack to boost
humans' digestion! But these aren't the only
fungi that can take over their hosts' minds.
According to National Geographic, the
Entomophthora muscae, translated from
Greek as "insect destroyer of the fly," is
able to take over flies' actions and cause
them to fly to the perfect height for spore
dispersal, which it does before then striking
a "death pose," the perfect angle for the fungus
to grow from its corpse and spread more spores.
There is also the Massospora cicadina, which
drugs its cicada hosts so much that it causes its
abdomen to partially fall off. The rest is similar
to what other fungi do to their hosts: move it to
an ideal climate for spreading spores, kill it,
then take over its body and do it all over again.
The one thing consistent in all of these
cases, however, is that infection occurs
exclusively through airborne spore dispersal,
an element that was present in the games but was
removed from the HBO show. Although "The
Last of Us" certainly did its homework,
the part about infecting its hosts by biting them
appears to be purely the work of zombie fiction.
"The Last of Us" airs on HBO and
HBO Max Sundays at 9 p.m. ET.